hey youtubers is Charlie and Warner
Brothers just got a case of sequel itis
they announced nine untitled Batman vs
Superman sequels or DC movies they're
gonna follow Batman vs Superman so this
video is gonna be a breakdown of what
those might be about half of them are
pretty obvious choices like Superman and
Batman sequels it's when we start
thinking about the other four or five
that things get interesting and if
you're just finding me for the first
time I do Marvel and DC videos every
week be sure to subscribe to get
everything so let's get started with the
dates I'm just gonna read these off
Batman vs Superman just got moved
forward to March 25th 2016 Warner
Brothers decided that they didn't want
to compete with Captain America 3 those
two movies were set to come out of the
same day it was kind of funny because
when they made the announcement Marvel
people were tweeting these Captain
America panels from the comics showing
him being a badass standing his ground
mostly is just big studios slapping each
other around which is kind of funny but
the reason why we should care about this
is because we get to see the movie two
months earlier than we normally would
which is awesome so then we get into the
mystery movies here's what the dates are
August 5th 2016 June 23rd 2017 November
17th 2017 March 23rd 2018 July 27th 2018
April 5th 2019 June 14 29 teen April 3rd
2020 and then June 19 2020 so that is a
freaking giant list why did they
announce all those movie dates without
announcing any names the best theory
I've seen is that Warner Brothers knew
that they were going to move Batman vs
Superman and bout to marvel
in addition Marvel announced six
untitled films the week before Comic Con
so Warner Brothers just wanted to make
the announcement to save some face both
Studios absolutely do not care what each
other does like the people at Marvel
don't care what the people at DC do or
is really Warner Brothers that make the
movies and the people at Warner Brothers
don't care what the people at Marvel do
it's really the big money people the
CEOs and the board members of those
companies that care a lot it's a
situation where someone in a boardroom
says we need to make a billion dollars
each year each one of your comic book
movies makes X dollars so we need to
make X per year for the next five years
it's a financial thing which sounds kind
of silly and it totally is but what are
these movies going to end up being back
in June there was a list that's
supposedly leaked from inside Warner
brother
the interesting thing about that list is
that the release dates that were on it
were completely false but the titles
were totally right that included like
the Shazam movie the Green Lantern flash
crossover the Maine is still sequel
supposedly Warner Brothers was going to
announce that at comic-con but maybe
when they learned that Marvel wasn't
going to announce any of their mystery
movies they decided to hold off there
were six movies that were listed here's
what they are there was Shazam
Sandman Justice League Wonder Woman the
flash Green Lantern team-up and Man of
Steel 2 so that's only six of the nine
that Warner Brothers announced dates for
so here's the status update for what's
going on with them so first up is Shazam
that movie has been in development for a
long time with the rock a long time ago
he was attached to the project but it
just didn't end up happening he's still
at the top of their list so think of it
as like a rock Shazam movie it will
happen and when it does happen it will
be a rock movie so then there's Sandman
this project has an even bigger history
back in December of 2013 it was reported
that David s Goyer the guy that wrote
the first Man of Steel movie was writing
a script for Joseph gordon-levitt to
direct their version was the Neil
Gaiman's Sandman not the Wesley Dodds
Sandman that was part of JSA before that
james mangold the guy that did the last
Wolverine movie with Hugh Jackman he was
gonna do it as a TV show with HBO that
was pre Game of Thrones
pre True Blood so I'm totally not
surprised that HBO did not move forward
with it just because they hadn't had a
really big fantasy hit yet and if you
did hear about it there is a CW series
that's also in development although it's
currently a status unknown it's for our
man though not Sandman I know the flash
hasn't even started
but the CW is developing a Rex Tyler our
man TV show so moving along Justice
League this is all but confirmed pretty
much it's the same team that's doing
Batman vs Superman the latest that we
heard about this is that Zack Snyder is
gonna direct and the writer from Batman
vs Superman Chris Terrio is gonna write
it to basically everyone that's working
on the movie and starring in it he's
just gonna continue on and do Justice
League no surprise there
it just means that Warner Brothers
really likes the stuff that Zack Snyder
has been turning in every day for the
movie so far there's also the rumor that
they're gonna roll right into production
of Justice League after Batman vs
Superman traps so moving along to Wonder
Woman this would be gal gadot's solo
movie this is really hard to predict
because they have been very secretive
about her role in Batman vs Superman
she wasn't in the teaser at Comic Con
and they've only showed her costume
which is exactly what the earlier leaks
had shown it to be there was some images
from the set of her getting into her car
but so far we know almost nothing about
her character
I will go on record as saying that I
totally love gal gadot but until I see
footage of her in Batman vs. Superman
I'm gonna withhold my judgement
moving along the flash Green Lantern
team-up this is gonna make some of you
guys short-circuit a little bit mostly
because there's no way they're gonna
like Grant Gustin be in the movie as the
flash Jeff Jones already went on record
during Comic Con as saying the TV shows
and the movies are gonna be separate
universes and will continue to be that
way for the foreseeable future
at least until executives at Warner
Brothers get fired and new ones come in
that want a shared universe and
everybody knows what went down with Ryan
Reynolds Green Lantern I think we'd all
as fans rather see him in a Deadpool
movie then do another Green Lantern
movie as for why they picked both those
characters for a team-up Barry Allen and
Hal Jordan are both from Central City so
that's probably why they want to pair
them up and lastly on to the Man of
Steel sequel this was originally going
to be what Batman vs. Superman was until
they stuffed it full of so many a-list
actors and characters that it turned
into a Justice League prequel the next
solo Superman movie is just gonna be its
own separate thing it's just gonna have
a smaller cast and it'll focus more on
Henry cavils character so like I said
the dates for when those movies are
gonna come are kind of in question but
the titles are solid like those are the
movies that they're planning on doing my
thoughts are that they're gonna focus on
the Holy Trinity first just because
they're they're a list talent Superman
Batman Wonder Woman Justice League so
it's likely that Justice League will be
the first one after Batman vs Superman
they'll just roll right into production
after the last day of filming on Batman
vs Superman it just makes sense from a
production standpoint if Batman vs
Superman is going to be successful and
they have all the same crew under
contract and all the same actors then
they'll just roll right in with maybe
like a short break they'll just want to
maintain people's attention spans
because it takes so long to make these
movies the sooner you start the sooner
you can release it so after that there's
a big question mark do they go with the
next Man of Steel movie or do they go
with a solo Batman movie the first movie
for Ben Affleck
I definitely think they'll let Ben
Affleck write his first solo Batman
movie they might not let him direct it
just because of scheduling conflicts it
would be crazy for him to do both it'd
just be nearly impossible directors on
those movies basically go without sleep
for two years straight acting on top of
that would make it almost impossible
without a life model decoy so after that
we basically have six movies figured out
there's still three left
what are those gonna be right now the
best rumors are Metal Men Suicide Squad
and Justice League two of all those
Justice League two seems the most likely
sequels are always way easier to get
made than unfamiliar characters then
starting new franchises essentially here
to think of each team of superheroes as
their own franchise they have to be able
to stand on their own ass comic book
fans the Metal Men and The Suicide Squad
are totally familiar but whenever
studios think about developing these
franchises they're thinking about people
that have never read a comic book
they're thinking about like the Horde of
people who will go see movies and pay
for tickets but have absolutely no idea
who these characters are so Suicide
Squad I totally buy as like an
Expendables type movie if you ever saw a
John Carpenter's Escape from New York or
escape from Los Angeles they were
awesome movies but Snake Plissken the
main character gets dumped into an urban
war zone with a kill switch wired into
his brain
Amanda Waller did the exact same thing
during arrow Suicide Squad episode last
year think of a Suicide Squad movie as a
hundred million dollar version of that
arrow episode Metal Men is the big
question mark as an alternative choice
of that I really think that they should
do a movie centered on a villain like
make the villain the protagonist of a
movie how many of you guys would pay to
go see movie about dark side or Sinestro
or Jason Todd or some other DC big
villain I feel like that's something
that people want and would be a lot of
fun to make it's something that hasn't
been done by DC or marvel yet though but
now it's your turn let me know in the
comments what DC movies do you want to
see them make in related news I'm seeing
Ninja Turtles tonight it's gonna be fun
in a whole different way think guardians
of the galaxy was so you should all go
see it but just remember that it's
supposed to be a fun movie not an
oscar-winning movie I'll be posting my
review for that tomorrow morning don't
worry there'll be spoiler warnings you
can click right here to get that I'll
add the annotation as soon as I post it
and you can click here to get a
breakdown of the Batman vs Superman
trailer at Comic Con thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you